so it's not a secret that not every 2020
Democratic presidential candidate is all
in for Medicare for all or even for
similar sort of universal coverage
proposals and one of those people is Joe
Biden Joe Biden has now said more about
the specifics of his health care
proposal and it's so outrageous that
more than half of Americans straight-up
can't afford it and what I mean by that
is Joe Biden was interviewed on whu-oh
TV the other day as many of you know
local news stations are crazy about
copyrights so I'm not going to play any
clips for you but you can easily find
the interview online and check it out in
full and in this interview with the TV
station Joe Biden says that his approach
is not a Bernie Sanders esque
medicare-for-all approach which we knew
it's building on Obama care and Biden
specifically says that he wants to
further subsidize private insurance
which is completely broken of course in
order to reduce yearly co-pays to $1,000
so for context a lot of the plans that
Biden is talking about have $2,000 a
year co-pays or I'm sorry deductibles I
said I think I said copay but I mean
deductible he wants to reduce to $1,000
deductible plans that right now might
have a $2,000 deductible or a $2,500
deductible and he's also open to a
public option and the primary problem
with all of this is that it's completely
unaffordable for hundreds of millions of
people and it doesn't actually address
the real issues with our health care
system and I'll explain to you both of
those points you might remember that a
few months ago we did a story about a
study which found that presented with an
unexpected $400 emergency expense 40% of
the country can't afford it and by can't
afford it it means they either would
have to take out a loan or go into debt
charge it and pay it off at interest or
borrow from family or get a payday loan
imagine which is the worst opportunity a
possibility in order to cover the
unexpected $400 expense Joe Biden is
saying I will further subsidize
insurance in order to reduce the yearly
deductible from whatever it is 20
five hundred two thousand sometimes even
more down to a thousand dollars
out-of-pocket max if 40% can't afford an
unexpected $400 expense then certainly
more than half of the country can't
afford a thousand dollar deductible
above and beyond premiums and
medications and so on and so forth
now what this also ignores of course is
the cost of the plans themselves Biden's
talking just about lowering the
deductible to $1,000 and then Biden adds
I guess sort of like as a wink-wink or
an attempt to bring in some of the
people who understand how broken our
health care system is Biden says that
he's also open to a public option and
sure a public option is a fine idea if
you are comparing between what we have
now and what we have now plus a public
option sure I'll take the public option
but a Congressional Budget Office study
found that a public option would
basically only lower monthly premiums by
7 to 8% this barely makes a dent
especially when you consider how quickly
premiums are going up year after year
Biden also repeats in this interview
what is basically a Republican talking
point which is that under Bernie Sanders
Medicare for all plan you would lose
your insurance it's incredibly dishonest
it's not true the way it would work is a
public option would be put in place
immediately during the four-year phase
into Medicare for all during which the
age for Medicare eligibility gets
lowered and lowered until everybody is
in to say you lose your insurance under
Bernie's plan is incomplete at best and
completely dishonest and a Republican
talking point at worse this is the worst
part of Joe Biden these are Republican
for-profit health insurance company
talking points and Joe Biden is
repeating them now I will you know try
to find some kind of silver lining here
the one thing I appreciate about Joe
Biden is he's being upfront with us he's
not for Medicare for all and he's
telling us he's not for Medicare for all
we can debate it we can discuss whose
plan is the best we can discuss whose
plan would be best for low income middle
whatever Joe Biden is not playing coy
the way that Kamala Harris
did we're on a CNN Town Hall Town Hall
she said medicare-for-all is the way and
then the next day put out a statement
saying medicare-for-all would be one way
and tweaking Obamacare is another way
that I would also be open to Joe Biden
has been upfront he's not for Medicare
for all
he's been upfront with the wealthy
donors behind closed doors but it went
public saying you're privileged status
will remain unchanged if I become
president of the United States he is
safe for the super-rich he's been
upfront I don't agree with Biden's
politics I think it's terrible but he is
not sugarcoating it to appear more
progressive than he is and we can
actually evaluate it for what it
actually is rather than having to read
between the lines and what my assessment
is is that it's horrible and I
completely disagree with it today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman if you've not already
heard about blink Asst it's amazing it's
an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a 15 minute audio
book you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on
blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n